let's just bring you a bit of breaking
news about Pope Francis we know that he
is being taken to hospital but we've
heard that his health is improving after
he was hospitalized with a respiratory
infection his treatment is continuing
Vatican spokesman Matteo Bruni said in a
statement on Thursday his Holiness Pope
Francis rested well during the night his
clinical picture is gradually improving
and he is continuing his planned
treatment the statement said this is the
hospital where the pope is at the moment
this morning after breakfast he read
some papers and resumed work also
hearing that he was able to pray in a
private hospital chapel as well so the
word from the Vatican is that all there
are concerns about Pope francis's Health
he does appear to be improving in that
hospital we can see there